I'm a lawyer copywriter Doctor music
producer personal trainer software
engineer DJ I want to know can AI do my
job
I'm a software engineer
where I work we're always trying to know
where can I find the best craft beer
please generate the code for a website
using HTML CSS and flask that tells me
where there's craft beer near me
this is just raw code you actually need
to run the code somewhere I'm copying
pasting the code into separate files and
it generates a website how cool here's
our website all three pieces the back
end the front end and The Styling did
actually make something that was human
readable that that generates a website
that we can look at and understand what
it does does seem like a huge feat to me
I'm a doctor this prompt is something
that a patient might enter I have a
fever rash and body aches the rash looks
like small welds on my genitals do I
have monkey pox
the response is pretty solid in the
sense that it's unlikely that you have
monkey pox the specific thing I got
right was that the monkey pox rash is
actually not prominent on the genital
area it goes on to say that a rash in
the general area most likely is an STI
the rest of the answer is just fluff
talking to your healthcare provider
which is pretty obvious can AI do my job
I don't think it's there yet I think the
AI right now is really good for a first
year medical student
I'm a graphic designer Rebrand the
McDonald's logo as vegan
I'm seeing four image variations it's
struggling with text it's looking sort
of like characters but in some sort of
fictional language I wouldn't send any
of these straight away to McDonald's
they do each need a little bit of work
the fourth one I think is maybe the
strongest it's leaning towards more
organic colors overall I don't think AI
can do my job I kind of see this as a
more evolved Pinterest I can use it as a
base for inspiration but I don't think
it will replace me all together or so I
hope
I'm a therapist people come to me when
they want help in dating or
relationships please answer the
following question in a way a
relationship therapist would why do I
always fight with my partners
conflicts are a natural part of any
relationship fighting or arguing is not
necessarily a sign of a bad relationship
great some possible factors include
communication issues stress and life
events different conflict styles how do
I know what my conflict style is reflect
on your past conflicts observe your
behavior during conflicts most people
are incapable of reflecting on their
conflict style during conflicts so while
this is great information I'm not sure
how actionable it is what AI has done is
it's just dumped a bunch of information
were I to be a client I would probably
want my money back that's just me so can
AI do my job I would say have self-help
books done my job people don't lack
knowledge they lack the ability to
follow through
I'm a stand-up comedian and I want to
know if an AI can do my job write a 100
word minimum funny stand-up comedy joke
let me go ahead and perform this and
we'll see what we got online dating what
a wild ride that is you know what they
say swipe right for love and left for
well probably just another cat person
but hey at least it's better than
meeting someone at a bar and realizing
you have the same dad again like what
side are you using ancestry.com that's a
little creepy it has the Cadence right
which is what's so fascinating to me and
it's kind of creeping me out I did think
it was cute when it was like oh swipe
left on a cat person although let's be
honest that's a little feline phobic I'm
not concerned about the AI yet it could
take a crappier comedian's job but it
can't take mine
I'm a lawyer my client is asking me
whether or not they can sell someone's
health information please write a legal
memorandum about this
in a true legal memorandum it would give
you which sections of the regulation
you're talking about which this is not
doing it doesn't say what the penalties
are is it criminal is it civil I don't
really know where it's getting its
information I don't know how much I can
trust this if it were like a legal
associate I would say go back and do a
better job
I'm a news anchor I want to know if AI
can do my job I have given the AEI some
text to read
a forest fire has blazed through a large
part of the Southern mountain region of
the country she didn't sound natural he
sounded like a machine speaking the lips
look weird it looked like the lips did
not belong to the face and provide Aid
to those affected when I speak I'm
moving my hands but I'm also moving some
of my body she wasn't doing that I do a
newscast in Spanish
now let's see how it does with the
Spanish newscast on incendio Forrestal
ha effectado una Grand Park de la region
it sucked in Spanish she actually threw
in some Spanglish there miles to Hector
is and the accent I have Casado she
definitely struggled there the AI cannot
take my job for now
I'm a bartender surprise me with a Twist
on a Negroni and give it a name
fill a mixing glass with ice add the Gin
Campari and sweet vermouth gently muddle
two to three fresh Sage leaves in the
glass stir the mixture until well
chilled Express the orange peel over the
drink release the oils and use it as a
garnish there you go you have your Sage
Negroni so it's a good classic Negroni
I'm not really getting sage just adding
the sage leaves was not very creative AI
didn't ask me any follow-up questions I
would say what do you like is there a
style of gin that you like I think if
you want to have a truly bespoke
cocktail you gotta go see a bartender
I'm a screenwriter
I'm going to give this AI a prompt that
describes a scene in my latest movie and
to see how well it can match it in this
scene set in 1949 three World War II
widows toast their younger sister Ruby's
wedding
exterior Beach day Mildred Shirley and
Charlotte Frolic at the shoreline of the
beach and may you never have to
experience the Heartbreak that we did
the character literally says exactly
what like you want the story to do
what's going on Ruby seems tense I don't
know but I'm going to find out just very
on the nose dialogue there's a lot of
parentheticals describing how the
characters saying the Line This is a
screenwriter no no you start to tip into
the director's territory I think that AI
can help with my my job in conceptual
brainstorming playing out scene ideas if
you get stuck on a scene but overall I
don't think AI can do my job
I'm a music producer I'm writing a song
for a pop client please write this song
and include chords for the guitar the
client is heavily influenced by Lana Del
Rey
it looks like we've gotten a chord
structure and some lyrics a typical
progression so not too interesting but
that's okay so let's make a beat when I
work with an artist that's looking for a
specific influence I'll think about the
BPM that that artist usually goes for
[Applause]
okay this is pretty good it's a good
start another great day in the city I'm
feeling lost oh Such a Pity City Lights
and heartbeats
you walk in and make me complete I like
that it's a starting point of course
some of the lyrics are super corny I
will admit a lot of the time that's how
it starts for me right now these
programs can't do my job
I'm a journalist I'm the reviews editor
at wired and I test products for a
living so I asked chat gbt to write a
review of a product that I've actually
written about in the style of my own
writing
when it comes to electric skateboards
there are plenty of options to choose
from a little boring this is pulling in
data specifically from my review and so
it has a lot of similar characteristics
and sentences that I might typically use
unfortunately I think it's Stripped Away
a lot of the personality in the original
review it kind of just took a lot of the
basic details and spit out this thing
that is kind of generic as for things
that did right it actually brought out a
lot of these specs like the 3000 watt
Motors the 26 miles per hour speeds when
reading this review it almost sounds
like I could have written it by just
reading a press release the AI cannot
physically handle this product it's not
exactly testing the product itself at
that point can you really trust where
the source is coming from asking chat
gbt to write a review based in my voice
is definitely weird
I'm a circus artist
what would I ask the AI to do hmm I
don't think there's anything that I can
think of that I would have the AI do for
me
I'm a copywriter
McDonald's just went 100 vegan write
several taglines
so we've got veganize your taste buds
today feels like a used car salesman no
animals harmed only flavor enhanced I
don't ever go to a fast food restaurant
and say I really want my flavor enhanced
that's not something I'm ever looking
for our last one here is wow very short
we've got It's Time to Go Green did it
run out of um words it typed up some
general ideas which actually could help
if you were brainstorming and you're
like I have nothing at all AI could do
my job at a very like a Monday morning
no coffee kind of way if you wanted to
pay no money and get a bad product sure
hey I could do my job
I'm a personal trainer please design a
fat burning weekly at home workout plan
this is definitely a typical plan that
someone might want to burn calories with
a full body workout you're also doing
some type of pull workout that's going
to work your back your posterior chain
and you're also doing some kind of push
so I will say that I like that that it's
giving a full range of those types of
exercises most people know what a
push-up is but do they know how to
correctly do a push-up it's saying three
sets of eight to ten reps but how much
time is in between each set ideally you
would want to be able to see the client
in person or on a virtual call so that
you can see what their form looks like I
don't think AI can do my job
I'm a DJ I have my radio show coming up
I play uplifting disco music for about
two hours make a full playlist slash set
list for my show
it's hitting the Disco on the head for
sure I've played a few of these artists
on my show before so it's definitely
getting pretty close to maybe what a
tracklist would be one of these tracks
Gotta Keep On by sweet cream I looked it
up and there's no trace of it on the
internet anywhere where did it get this
song from does the song actually exist
AI can make a playlist being able to
look out into a room and look out into a
dance floor and say okay people are
tired let me match that energy I don't
think that it can do that based on what
I've seen
I'm a voice actor
shouldn't cost the Earth we've created a
new line of compostable shoes that are
made from sustainable materials I've
asked the AI to read this copy
let's hear this thing
fashion shouldn't cost the Earth we've
crew line of compostable
hey but not great it's very
computer-like it has a strange Cadence
and so it ends every sentence like this
sustainable
which is not the way a human talks it
can't change on the Fly is there a joke
that I'm supposed to get in the next
line it doesn't understand all those
things the things that come from like
life experiences it's never going to be
like the thing that you're going to use
for like McDonald's commercials it's
going to be like the things that no one
really likes to do anyway like 400 hours
of instruction manuals or something like
that can AI do my job kinda but not
really well although it still freaks me
out
I'm an influencer and I want to know if
AI can do my job I want chat gbt to help
me with an IG caption that's a picture
of me smiling standing at the top of my
Matra in Paris
Standing On Top of the World or at least
on top of mamatra smiley face eyes the
view from here is breathtaking the
Sakura cord in my back reminding me of
the city's Rich history and culture
feeling grateful and inspired what a day
it has been hashtag grateful this is
like really strong but it doesn't
necessarily capture how I would speak my
audience would know that this is not me
probably from the overwhelming amount of
emojis I would probably say like hey
y'all or like sis that was amazing this
AI program cannot do my job but it's
very close
I'm a chef write a recipe for an Indian
restaurant meal include a protein
marination
it's got definitely a lot of spices that
you use in Indian cooking it's actually
missing a key component it didn't
include yogurt which kind of acts as a
binding agent 400 Degrees 20 to 25
minutes for chicken it would probably
dry it out overall I would say it's like
a nice 8 out of 10 dish I do think a
substantial part of being a chef is that
creativity and coming up with dishes so
in terms of that aspect of the job I
think AI comes dangerously close to
being able to do my job
I'm a translator
please translate the opening paragraph
of The Sun Also Rises into Korean
structural sentence pretty good but
there are so many mistakes like if you
see the second sentence this is wrong
translation in Korean we have casual
form and then also respectful form this
AI translation use basic written form in
first sentence but in the second
sentence he used like respect for form
it's not consistent AI cannot do my job
maybe someday it can do it but so far
it's like it made so many mistakes
I'm a firefighter
there's no way AI can do my job
[Music]